اذا ابدا معك بيسان ابو كويك وانت تقفين
امام هذه المحكمه التي تشهد هذه المحاكمه
التاريخيه اليوم في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده استنفار امني كبير واجراءات كبيره
تتخذها الاجهزه المختلفه في نيويورك في
صوره هذا الحدث وكيف تشهده مدينه
طبعا المدينه في حاله استنفار امني شديد
خصوصا هنا في محيط المحكمه ومكتب المدعي
العام بحيث
سيمطل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دوونلد
ترامب امام قاضن هنا وليسلم نفسه امام
القضاء طبعا المحاكمه ستتم في وقت لاحق ان
قرر القاضي ان التهم الموجهه لترامب مبنيه
على اساس يسمح
يعني تحويلها الى محاكمه ربما كما ترون
نحن نتوقع قدوم ترامب ننتظر مغادرته برج
ترامب او ترامب تاور في موقع اخر من مدينه
منهات في نيويورك ولكن هنا تواجد مكثف
للاعلام اعداد مهوله من الصحفيين هنا بحيث
حتى يصعب لنا نحن التحرك بسهوله تواجد
لعناصر الشرطه كبير جدا لان على الارجح
سيدخل من هذا الباب الجانبي هنا ان لم
تحدث مفاجاه ويستخدم الباب الرئيسي لهذه
المحكمه طبعا حين يحضر الى هنا سيتوجه الى
مكتب الادعاء العام سيقوم بتسليم نفسه
سيتم اخذ بصماته عاده مع المتهمين يتم اخذ
صورتهم حتى اللحظه من غير الواضح ان كان
سيتم ذلك معه وفق محاميه لن يكبل بالاصفاد
لانه سيكون بمرافقه وحمايه شرطه الخدمه
السريه من بعد ذلك سيكون في موقع ينتظر
فيه وليس في زنزانه كما عاده يجري في هذه
الحالات ومن ثم سيمتل امام القاضي بعد نحو
ساعه وربع من الان حيث ستوجه له رسميا
لائحه الاتهام التي ما زالت قيد السريه
ولكن وفق التسريبات هي 34 تهمه تضم تهما
جنائيه وتهم مت
بتزوير السجلات ماليه وهذا ما سمعناه من
ترامبي يهاجم المدعي العام بقضيه التسريب
قائد لان بانه يجب ايضا اتهام المدعي
العام نفسه ومقاضاته لان هذه التسريبات
وفق قول ترامب صدرت عن مكتب الادعاء العام
طبعا لا نعرف او نعلم ما هي المصادر التي
تم
الاستناد اليها في هذه المعلومات ولكن
ايضا هنا في نيويورك هذه القضايا عاده تتم
تحت اطار الجنح ولكن هذا المدعي العام
يبدو انه رفعها وفق ما يقا- ينقل من
تسريبات الى جنايات ترامب يصف ما يحدث
بانها ملاحقه سياسيه له وتصيد له لذا نرى
هذا المشهد غير المسبوق بسبب يعني جو
مشحون سياسيا
وايضا بسبب كون ان هذا امر لم تعاهده
الولايات المتحده في